hello everyone.welcome to see ETV hosted
by cloud on air where we host live
webinars every Tuesday today we are
going to be talking about neck
networking 103 my name is Stephanie Wong
developer advocate for Google cloud and
today I'm joined by banal Shah who is a
networking specialist and customer
engineer for Google cloud last time we
spent a couple sessions with Ryan
principle who's also on her team
covering networking 101 and 102 where we
talked about VP C's VP see appearing we
also covered interconnect routing shared
VP C's so we're gonna continue speaking
on that topic but diving a little bit
deeper into security and best practices
there so before we get started I also
wanted to mention that you all have the
opportunity to ask questions throughout
the session we will have live Googlers
answering those on the platform and at
the end we'll save some time for you all
to ask questions as well we'll collect
them and then we'll jump back on and
answer them at the end so without
further ado take it away Thank You
Stephanie hi everyone I am Vanessa
networking specialist at Google I work
with our customers with the networking
requirements and architecture on Google
cloud so today we are going to talk
about security you know security network
security is a big part of infrastructure
design you know whether you're deploying
your environment on Prem or in cloud
right there is a requirement to secure
your resources today we will talk about
some of the best practices and how you
secure environment in Google cloud so
first thing you will start with whenever
you start deploying a project first
thing you'll do is spin up a VPC by
definition VPC is an isolated domain
where no one has access to it unless you
allow access
so as you're adding users and assigning
them I am Rose a good practice is to
follow the principle of least privilege
so understand the users function and
then only allow as much access the user
needs to do their job
this way you reduce errors due to miss
configuration and thereby reduce
downtime so this is relating to I am
policies Identity and Access Management
permissions and roles that's correct
and then you start deploying instances
in your V PC at that point you want to
restrict flows to your instances that's
how you protect your instances for this
you use firewall rules you know we'll
talk a little bit more about firewall
rules but this is a good time before you
start spinning up your instances right
it's a good time to sit down with your
application team and network and
security teams together to identify what
flows the application needs right you do
want to make sure the application runs
but at the same time you want to protect
your instances from unwanted traffic all
right now you have your V PC set up the
next thing you want to do is connect
back to on-prem so we have few ways we
are able to do this so let's say you
want to talk to your Google services
like G suite so in this case from
on-prem to G suite you can deploy the
rack peering where you pier your router
with one of Google's routers in the
closest peering location and then Google
is your next hop for all the Google
services traffic this way given that
Google is your next hop you are not
going over the internet crossing
multiple ear sense so that reduces your
latency and gives you better performance
now you also want to have connectivity
between your service and you want
private IP connectivity between this
right couple options right you can do
cloud VPN cloud with the N is our side
to side IPSec VPN the traffic goes over
the Internet
but it is fully encrypted so it is still
secure cloud VPN is a good solution when
you have lower bandwidth requirement and
it's very quick to set up and get going
now we do how customers sometimes they
do not want to react their traffic over
the Internet at all or they have very
large volumes of traffic so you're
talking about tens of gigs of data right
so for this we have dedicated in the
connect options so Derry care in a
connect again you connect your on-prem
and meet us at one of the co locations
and connect directly to Google cloud
from there you pull
attachment and cloud router in your V PC
so you have connected it directly into
your V PC and then between the cloud
router and your on-prem router you run
link-local bgp to exchange routes so
again this is internal communication
across that is internal communication
say servers where talk is in private IP
so 10-10-10 one can talk to 192 168 so
we have the connectivity setup now
oftentimes we see right customers come
in they have an architecture on prem and
they are using a lot of vendor solutions
like next-gen firewall ideas IPS and
they would like to carry that
architecture into google cloud right by
way of our partner solutions they are
able to do that so they can work with
their partners and deploy the same
solutions in their google cloud
environment ok so just to reiterate you
are able to use third-party
appliances and bring them over to GCP
absolutely that way we're able to kind
of meet you where you are you can
continue to react attacked in the same
way yes you know I always look at what
Google offers and then you know like I
said customers have their solutions they
also want to work with the same vendors
that they are then we have that
capability in our marketplace you can
find those vendors so now if you deploy
their applications in Google Cloud and
you want to scale so you're going to
front it with a load balancer so
Google's global load balancers provide
you edge protection from l3 and l4
attacks so Google's global load balancer
also uses any cached IP that is one IP
advertised globally so you can front-end
your application which is one IP and you
remember the power the Google's global
infrastructure right just by the way of
the infrastructure that we have
customers are able to have backends in
different regions you know behind their
load balancers so what this does is it
brings the workloads closer to the user
so your end-user will see less latency
and hence improved performance right you
mentioned that this global load balancer
offers l3 l4 protection are there any
other
small ways that you're able to protect
your application absolutely so we have a
product called cloud armor which
integrates with the load balancer and
provides additional protection from DDoS
and for the applications right in
addition we also have again partner
solutions that customers can use again
customers can be already using it and
they want more protection for their
specific protection for the application
then they are still these solutions are
still available rails awesome so now
let's take a little bit deeper dive into
some of these solutions right so when
you spin up instances in your VPC first
thing you're going to do is give it a
private IP and then you have an option
to add a public IP once you assign a
public IP to an instance remember this
instance is accessible from the rest of
the world so if your instance does not
need to be reachable from the outside
you don't need to add a public IP this
way you just reduce the attack surface
for the instance now there are cases
there where your instance can have a
private IP by still needs to go out
right it needs to get updates etc so it
will need outbound communication this we
enable using cloud NAT so cloud NAT is
Google's software-defined solution so
this is not a VM this is not an
appliance it's just a scalable software
solution it is regional so you add this
cloud NAT in each region then all the
subnets within that region can use this
nack to go out you also have control
over if you only want a specific sub
niche to go out you may still not want
some instances to go out at all so you
do have that kind of control so we also
have customers who might have been used
to using other architectural setups like
Bastian hosts their proxies in addition
to having this cloud that option when do
you recommend each kind of use case a
good question Stephanie so let's say I
have my instances and I need to SSH into
these right I don't want to ask OpenSSH
to the entire world right so I know who
needs to access so I can allow
my corporate eyepiece to access but
usually what you do this is where you
use a passion host right so you keep one
passion hose you allow access to that
host and these instances can only be
accessed from the bastion host that way
that is a lot more control access right
and you can also use proxies to go out a
lot of customers use that one more thing
I wanted to note so if you wanted to
talk to Google services or instances
wanted to reach Google services like
cloud storage or bigquery they can do
that using private IP so you don't need
to add a public IP just to access Google
service that's great and that's pretty
neat grace
awesome thank you so the next step is
you want to restrict flows to your
instance why do you want to protect your
instances we have Google's distributed
firewalls that will help with this how
are they different the right is
important to understand on the left side
you see is an architecture that you
traditionally see on Prem right so the
firewalls are closer to the edge all
traffic comes in and here's this
firewalls filtered through these
firewalls sometimes its firewalls can be
a choking point but more importantly
once the traffic leaves the firewall
there is little control no easy way to
control communication between instances
so on on Google cloud our firewall is a
distributed firewall and the way it
works is when a packet is trying to
reach an instance the firewall rules are
checked at that time and only if there
is a firewall rule that allows this
traffic to the instance will that packet
be allowed if there's no firewall rule
the packet does not reach the instance
so as you see in the diagram you can
control communication north-south as
well as east-west so if you look at this
diagram there are instances with a tag
called red tag and some instances with a
blue tag so when I add my firewall rule
my rule will look like sauce will be a
red tag we ends with red tag and
destination will be blue tags this is a
neat way to group together similar
function VMs
what happens as you now enabled
east-west communication another option
is to use service accounts on a VM
that's a bit more secure than tags
because with tags
it needs compute admin Estonia's compute
admin privilege to change the tag white
can be done while the VM is running so
depending on your use case you know you
have options I see and for the useless
of those who have projects in different
regions or just have shared V PC and
they want internal communication across
multiple projects how would you set up
firewalls or communication across them
yeah so a firewall rules is global
within a V PC right so if I have one V
PC and how multiple regions are still
going to be one firewall rule stable you
add your rules there now you mentioned
the case of shared with PC so in shared
V PC case there's one V PC in a host
project and now you are connecting a lot
of service projects and sharing these
subnets with the different service
projects so it's a it's a valid point
you want to control communication
between these projects right so you
still go back on the in the host project
and in those shared V PC and add
firewall rules day so share be PC is
still like a V PC you have the ability
to share your subnets down so I would
say subnet 1 shared with service project
1 and subnet 2 shared with service
project 2 I will put a rule so much
communication you know on these ports
these protocols to these VMs right is
allowed between these two projects cool
by default all ingress will be tonight
so only allow again another principle
has only allow access that you need to
by default egress is all allowed but
there may be cases where customers do
want to restrict that so you have the
ability to do that and here is an
example of how firewall rules can work
together in Google Cloud like we said
before before you deploy applications
it's a very good idea to know the flows
couple things just from experience right
troubleshooting gets easier you have a
blueprint anytime an applique
there's issue with the communication you
can look at the blueprint and validate
the flows are allowed you know firewall
rules are not the cause of downtime the
other thing is firewall rules are a
finite resource so it is important to
plant them before you start adding and
we talked about tags I'm gonna just show
you an example how you can reduce the
number of firewall rules just using tags
so in this diagram right on the right is
my management subnet there are my
management william's
that will have access to all the
instances right so if you look at the
second rule below that I have written my
source is going to be management subnet
then my destination is all instances so
actually from the drop-down in the
console you can say all instances in the
network and then you allow specific
ports in this case I want to allow SSH
and then I also want to allow ICMP so
now the next thing is I have web servers
right I will group all the web servers
together based on function and add a tag
www and then these web servers want to
talk to app servers over specific ports
then I will add a rule saying all VMS
with the tag
ww those are my source can access VMs
with the tag app and then the access
should be allowed for these ports and
these protocols in this case HTTP and
HTTPS so outside of just the the
limitation of firewall rules are there
other reasons why tagging in these
firewall rules would be a benefit yeah
tagging definitely helps you group
together similar instances so another
application comes onboard and you have
the same rules you already allow the
teachers have to give the right tag to
the instances right so the fool is
already there you can reuse and remember
firewall rules are a finite resource
yeah so you want to make sure you
efficiently plan your firewall drains
firewall rules are also important
between VPC pairings so it's critical
that you allow only the flows that you
want just a little bit on VPC peering
right VPC peering within Google Cloud
our VPC is global so if Rodino VPC you
had instances running in us west and
Europe these are these talk to each
other so you do not need to peer these
two together right these are still
within the single VPC and then they can
talk to each other but there are use
cases like SAS services like a large we
use right a large organization having
multiple departments they have their
different projects and yet they need
some communication to be allowed between
cross project so that's where you peer
with PCs and you pur between projects or
across organizations now when you peer
the routes are exchanged between these
to be PCs right so in this example we PC
Enterprise one has access has a route to
the subnets of a physicist why are the
peering link vice-versa VPC SAS has
access to enterprise Sumner's why are
the we disappearing link so now it is
the firewall rules that will control
which instances start to which instances
right so this is still internal
communication across disparate or
separate B pcs yet you're still able to
maintain that fine-grained control using
these firewall rules yes absolutely
and yes the communication is not going
out it is still within the Google Cloud
and the instance is able to talk to each
other using private IP keep in mind the
firewall rules tables are not exchanged
between peers and this is for security
reasons your tags also will not be
transferred so you will use subnets as
source for your V PC for the peer BBC
okay so we have the firewall rules set
up next thing we need to know is when
you start deploying in cloud you want
visibility similar to what you have on
Prem or other environments you want to
be able to see what is going in and out
of your via V PC flow logs enables that
it captures all flows at the instance
levels or to and from the VM it is any
build at the subnet level and then if
whenever the flow reaches an instance or
flow goes out be this between VM to VM
or are we m
talking to on-prem environment or are we
I'm talking to the Internet you're able
to capture these flows our aggregation
is five seconds not in minutes so it is
pretty real talking some use cases for
VPC flow logs is when you are spinning
up a new environment you want to
troubleshoot so you go into flow logs
filter as you need and you can check
whether the flows are working as you
expect right so following this idea of
your blueprint you want to make sure
that everything is according to plan
according to your security policies when
you do look at these logs so what kind
of information does it actually capture
it actually captures a rich set of
information so if I take at any of the
flow log entry I will see connection
details so who is my source IP who is my
destination who is it talking to what
ports and protocols are used and then it
will give me details of the instance
that the flow is occurring to or from so
this is my source VM this is the name
this is the IP the subnet VPC and the
project that it lives in for the source
that is external it will also give me
what a SN is coming from reaching
incontinent details etc so it is pretty
rich I can actually take all this
information and put it into bigquery and
generate a lot of analytics out of it I
can actually generate a networking
dashboard who are my top talkers what is
the bandwidth utilization and egress
charge right so if I see egress by zones
you know how much if anybody tries looks
at the building is sometimes confusing
this will give you a chart and tell you
how much egress person yeah and that was
gonna be my other follow-up question is
about exporting these logs you mentioned
bigquery if I wanted to export to my cm
and correlate these Logs with other
systems that are amusing would that be a
possibility absolutely so all of our
logs go to start driver logging there's
our tool for cloud logging and from here
you have the capability to export it so
you can export to cloud storage you know
a lot of customers have requirement to
store logs for a certain amount of time
so you can just export it to cloud
storage and let it be there
exported to bigquery we just talked
about it lot of rich information and
using a data analytics platform it also
integrates with data studio which is our
visualization tool where you can create
charts at any time and you mentioned cm
we can actually stream live you saying
pops up to any device you want so good
use case for cm is you want to correlate
all the logs in one place so we have
that capability using putzi that's right
okay so now you have your applications
front ended with global load balancer
and you want to scale with that right so
global load balancer provides us a lot
of advantages so first of all you know
when you're using application use TLS
right wherever possible use TLS it
increases the security and Google does
not charge extra for it
now Google sorry global load balancer is
in any cast web so one web advertise
Clovelly so you have one DNS name
mapping to one IP and by virtue of our
global infrastructure here I have an
example where I have workloads in US
central u.s. West US east as well as
Asia right so my customers in Asia can
access the application you know with lot
less latency than if it were in u.s.
West now global load balancer supports
auto scaling what does that mean if I
have a region seeing a lot of traffic
and I plan you know I plan for the
capacity which is good for every day and
then suddenly there are times right end
of the year you have sudden spike in
traffic Black Friday you have sudden
spike in traffic you want your
application to be able to handle this
then the auto scaling feature will be
able to auto scale and add instances to
absorb that traffic and serve your users
in addition global load balancer also
can do cross region overflow so let's
say in u.s. East you're suddenly seeing
a lot of traffic and it may it may be
unexpected right but by the time you
figure out what's going on the global
load balances
intelligent enough to divert the traffic
to the next closest region so in this
case US central instances will start
picking up the traffic and your
customers will not see down time and
that's important that's amazing and this
is all supported of course by our large
number of points of presence and data
centers globally I see that our CDN is
also on this slide as well how does this
fit into this overall picture absolutely
so CDN enables you to cache content at
the edge so you may have frequent
requests for certain information you
enable CDN CDN integrates web load
balance HTTP HTTPS load balance array so
you enable CDN for your back-end service
and it will start caching content at the
edge so now when requests come in it
will be served at the edge now we just
offloaded your back-end servers from a
lot of requests ok it's another solution
that we have is cloud armor that
provides DDoS protection at the edge to
your applications cloud armor also
integrates with global load balancer now
we know right that instances are
protected by firewall rules cloud armor
works at the edge to restrict access to
the global bit because the global web
will have a public IP this way here in
this example I have instances at the
backend they are protected by firewall
rules remember global load balancers our
proxy load balancers so the source IP is
going to be different it's going to be
the load balancer IPS as seen from the
instance perspective right so that
traffic you want to make sure you only
allow the ports and protocols that you
want to allow the the traffic you want
to allow now at the edge the traffic is
coming from a client right so that's
where cloud armor comes in and it's
gonna you're gonna be having control
over which IPs
you're going to allow right so in this
case of as an example I'm gonna allow my
corporate IDs to access this load
balancer or I may have specific
customers I have this application for
and I'll allow only their IPs and then I
can say deny everything else
so this is sort of speaking to that
multi-layered defense where you know of
course we provided DDoS protection at
the load balancer level but from the
edge we want to protect from even
allowing traffic from those source edge
IPs absolutely now a lot of our
customers I know also wonder about being
able to not only whitelist IPs but also
have the ability to blacklist IPS is
that something that cloud armor would
enable it can absolutely so I have my
service open to everyone or who needs to
but something I I'm saying like you know
you're seeing the logs and you're
suddenly seeing traffic from somebody
don't want and you're gonna find those
IPS and say I don't want this particular
I don't know it's not my customer it's
not my corporate I need to block this IP
so you can add rules to your file to
your cloud or my policy specifically for
that IP or a set of IPs and restrict
that communication okay that's great so
that's a great way to block unwanted
yeah traffic all right
so here is an example that shows I have
my HTTP global load balancer configured
with the backends and I'm going to
configure cloud armor policy here my
corporate IP range is 50 dot 1.00 slash
16 so I'm going to add a rule to my
policy allow fifty dot 1.00 slash 16 now
as you see employees in San Francisco
and Singapore are going to be able to
access the service fine but you see
someone with an IP 121 one is coming in
and that is not your employee so that
traffic will be blocked
now one other question that I start to
think about is just the difference
between setting up cloud armor versus
also setting up firewall rules for your
specific compute instances yeah so
firewall rules protect the compute
instance so we will look at this example
right so my user comes in with an IP 51
1 5 and has access to the load balancer
rip right the load balancer is a proxy
load balancer so it's gonna
terminate that connection and open a new
connection to the back end so from my
instance perspective I have the source
as the load balancer IP and the
destination is my instance so the
firewall rule will have a source of
destination source of the load balancer
eyes array and the port let's say 4 4 3
please allow this traffic
anything else block the traffic mm-hm
but in this case if I were not having so
this allowed but there is no way my my
source will always be the load balancer
type in this case a second I remain the
same yes so how do I protect my front
end so cloud Armour will come in and say
ok I'll protect you from the client I
please right so that's where I'm saying
51 1 0 0 slash 16 is what I'm gonna
allow right and that can vary so much
more in terms of like the number of
clients I could be trying to access that
load balancer yes this this can be
globally right so great awesome alright
so I think let's try to look at some of
the configurations of what we talked
about right we talked about a lot of
things how does it look in Google Cloud
console now so I have some instances
created here I have a management
instance and I have assigned an external
IP to it now if you look at the other
instances they do not have external IP I
can try to go into any one instance and
we will see the configuration right so
my instance an instance is in u.s. twist
one piece owned has a primary IP does
not have an external IP I have also
added a tag to it saying www if you
remember of a previous example ok so now
I want to SSH into this instance so let
me SSH here so I'm gonna go into my
management instance and from there I can
access all the instances I also have
some instance groups here so we're gonna
walk through a global load balancer set
up my instance groups we'll also have
the
same tag so my template should have the
tags that I want to have okay so here I
am now I want to SSH into ten to one two
so this is my internal instance right so
remember I want to be able to go out to
get updates etc so I want external reach
ability so how do I do that right so I
need to add cloud NAT as we had
discussed earlier so to be able to find
cloud NAT you go under products
networking network services cloud NAT
and I have an add gateway configured
already we just go through the
configuration this is in my V PC and the
region us best one that's where my
instances are and here I'm saying all
subnets primary and secondary will be
able to access my cloud NAT I do have an
option to say specific sub nests right
so here I can say custom range and then
I will say only by demo my web servers
will be able to go out write things like
that so I have the option of doing that
I can also say only primary ranges
subnets can have secondary ranges but
you know you may not want those to go
out so you have control like that I
already have our gateway connected so
let's go to my instance and let's see if
we are able to go out yep without a
public IP I am able to go out so that's
pretty neat now let's look at our load
balancer setup so this was my next setup
we already saw this we talked about VPC
flow logs so I just want to walk through
one of the entry how it looks and what
information you are able to see so we
did SSH I am able to this is our start
driver login screen I am able to filter
so here I want to see who all SS aged
into my instance right so I will say
destination port 22 and the IP of the
instance that I want to look into and
here is a typical entry so I have
connection details the destination the
source in this case that says my
management VM and the destination port
is 22
so I know there was an SSH actions and
these are the details on the destination
instance it tells me the instance name
and the region and the project at the
instance lives in and of course there's
a timestamp and then there is a source
instance details if the source is in
evident because find similar instance
details if it is external it will give
you more details on the origin of the
user perfect it also tells me reporter
is destination that means the flow is to
my VM in this case all right now let's
quickly take a look at the global load
balancer setup so I have a load balancer
setup I have a global web and I have
HTTP enabled and I will have a back-end
to it
now I also have a cloud armor policy
configured here so go to network
security and cloud armor and then I have
a policy that will allow to everyone but
I know I don't want to allow specific
ranges so I will have one deny policy
and then I am okay to allow to my
corporate in this case I've allowed to
the rest of the world I can go and this
is my last rule is my default rule I can
go in and set it to deny if I do deny I
do have options to configure what kind
of response the user will see so it can
be 403 404 or 502 so you have the
flexibility of configuring that so I see
here this is how you whitelist versus
blacklist sir my key ranges absolutely
now let's look at some of the logs here
so I am I am gonna try to send this one
request to the user and I am able to see
because I have actually opened it up to
the world now if I look at any one
particular log entry
you will go into HTTP load balancer and
then you see an for security policy so
it will tell you this rule hit which
policy rule right now this flow head
which policy rule so in this case the
security policy was configured to accept
the name of the policy was cloud armor
policy GL be HTTPS and the outcome was
accept now I could have had a deny here
and it will show me which policy was
triggered and here is the detail of the
forwarding rule that was tried to access
and then the zone configuration alright
that's all I had great thank you I think
it was really nice to see visually in
terms of the flow logs between either
hitting the load balancer versus your
specific instances in the backend yes it
is actually I would highly encourage you
you know just go to Google cloud and
look at these options cloud armor sits
under and they talk security cloud and
act load balancing under networking
services yeah I see it's giving a lot of
options for reducing that attack so
first by preventing you from always
having any of your instances open to the
public so there's a lot of options here
so protector of eons and keep checking
we have a lot more features coming right
yeah well thank you so much we do have a
couple of minutes to just collect some
questions and we'll just be back in a
minute and we'll we'll try to answer
some of them
you
all right welcome back we have a few
questions that we'd love to get answered
for you all that we've just collected
the first one which is can I enforce
firewall rules for other services like
App Engine so you can app engine
firewalls use the same firewall rules
table so firewall rules work for GC g ke
App Engine okay great and the next
question is can I control communication
between two subnets using a third party
firewall so this is a good question so
let me say two subnets within a VP see
when you create sub nurse these are
local subnets and there will always be a
local route generated for that so if I
want to go for two subnet one VPC 1 2 7
a 2 V PC to a V PC one it's gonna be the
local generate locally generated route
so this communication cannot go to an
extra external next hop and come back
however between 2 V pcs so a good use
case for a third party firewall is you
have multiple V pcs and you want to see
communication between these two V pcs
that's when you use a third party
firewall you spin up an instance with
multi NIC and you can have one Nick in
each V pcs and that way your next hop so
when you want to communicate a subnet 1
you maybe see one with subnet 1 and V PC
2 you can configure the next hop as the
third party firewall and your
communication will go through the
firewalls of the firewall gets the
visibility it means together okay so
there's two things there you can set up
multiple Nick's on a single VM and then
also that if you are using a two subnets
on the same V PC those are actually
using local routes which is why you
wouldn't be able to use a third party
firm in that case yeah so even if you
add a route route can have priorities
right even if you add it out with a
lower priority - for two subnets within
the same V PC that route is going to be
disabled the local route will always be
preferred I do want to go back to your
point for third party photos yes you can
you Nene T is a multi Nick VM so typical
use case for third party firewall is you
have an outside interface and then you
have at least one inside interface so
you can have a multi NIC VM with up to 8
interfaces
and then you have the insight configured
and then the outside VPC so the instance
has a leg in each right and and then the
firewall controls a company can see okay
our next question is can i log firewall
rule activity which i think we might
have covered in the presentation but yes
actually yes you can log firewall rules
activity so for each rule there's an
option you can enable logging right so
all connections now this is not sampled
all connections will be logged I see
okay so it's a it's a good use case for
troubleshooting also when you suspect
something is going on you can start
logging
yeah so you want to measure and keep a
log of whether or not things were
accessed and whether your firewall rules
were being used and again these logs go
into our start driver logging mm-hm
so you are able to see it there as well
as exported to wherever you want okay
our next question here is when I block
traffic using cloud armor what response
code or message does the user receive so
when you configure a rule to deny you
have the option to configure what is the
message that you service see you can
configure a 404 every five or two or you
can say forbidden
so 403 okay and I think we saw that in
your demo yeah but you get that job
Johnston and our last one is can you
elaborate on how you control traffic
between projects that are using a shared
V PC yeah so sherry PC is a way to scale
with larger organizations right
typically on framesi you have network
and security functions so you have
network admins security admins and then
there are application web admins right
web admins don't necessarily spin up
subnets and at firewall rules where and
network admin needs to have control over
the you know the IP IPS that are being
used across projects a security rules
that are being added so shared VPC
enables that so your networking and
security function is centralized in the
host project that's where the VPC lives
now that VPC you share with different
projects
service projects so these other projects
like web projects you connect to the
host host
see and they're called service projects
so as we share subnets with these
service projects the compute admin over
there will be able to spin up instances
but not add firewall rules so the
firewall rules function still stays in
the host project and you still use
firewall rules to do right okay so you
again you do use firewall rules even if
you are using share PPC yes it is a
single VPC still right it is one V PC
and you still use the firewall rules
just that just the way you use with
other pcs great all right so I think
that's all the questions that we have
thank you so much for now again for
giving us this deep dive on security
best practices I've truly enjoyed going
you know more in depth about security
security and networking thank you very
much yeah thank you so much so please
again stay tuned we do have more
sessions coming up today at for cloud on
air our next one is power innovation for
s AP with Google cloud so stick around
thanks again thank you
you